tout c'est que sur ce plateau on avait
énoncé la possibilité de l'arrivée dans
danse avec les stars de pamela anderson
c'est moi qui l'ait dit oui du point
alors si on avait annoncé figurez-vous
que d'après les armes sont que nous
avons récupéré de ci de là en picorant
tu comme ça ça doit coûter 100 en
regardant touche pas à mon poste il dit
mais bon sang mais c'est bien sûr
mais quoi on n'a pas pensé à appeler et
la scoop parmi les scoops
ils ont fait quoi tf1 allait pas mal
c'est vrai ils ont appelé pamela et de
grèce et peut-être que pamela anderson
sera dans danse avec les stars et la
dent grâce à nous quoi ça nous avantage
et ne fera pas le cheikh lô est bon le
fait c'est vrai j'aimerais retrouver
ville de ses co stars david charvet est
pressenti pour être candidat dans un
match et c'est reda me jean reinhart à
malibu sûr j'ai eu dans la fosse il
avait regardé
allez allez vous pourrez plus précis sur
cette histoire de pamela anderson
effectivement la prod a appelé ils se
sont énervés vraiment ils s'en foutent
rien colère en disant mais comment vous
n'avez pas eu l'idée de pamela anderson
on vient d'en parler dans tpm paix c'est
dingue donc je le sais pas le producteur
évidemment de pamela est effectivement
du coup il y aura là tu veux pas qu'on
me dise vous le dira loi y aller il
s'intéresse pas été spectateur réalisé
par thierry série voilà je fais on aura
des risques non ah non non non pas tiré
j'ai donc braderie sucre non plus gérant
gérait pas plus que si j'enlève allez
c'est pas ça passera prix alors là je
vais l'expliquer donc si vous voulez ils
ont rappelé le producteur en lui disant
bon effectivement on la veut etc et donc
du coup ils sont en pleine négociation
s'est pas encore finalisé mais c'est en
bon chemin là l'a fait là seu - c'est au
moins 6 017 minimale 01 2010 même pas
bonjour la meuf
excusez moi mais sans me savais 5-0 non
[Rires]
bizarre et à moins de 5 0 la me faisais
pas ça la connaît pas mais là j'ai
rencontré oui non si bas si vous dites
5-0 machin gâteau avec sert il
oui je sais par l'ump font des animaux
oui bah oui donc oui mais en tout cas il
estime donc à part pamela anderson
qu'est-ce que tu as comme info alors
apparemment il y aura là la fameuse
jeunes artistes et louise qui était venu
hier louise martin le camarade jeu qui
sort bientôt d'ailleurs le 4 juillet le
compère de franck gastambide qui savent
mais oui bien sûr oui bien sûr mais il a
d'autres
est ce que vous seriez pas en train de
ramer petit peu la rio oui très bien
clément ray mince comme à là on est
demain nous appartient à l'acteur dennis
et eris mitonnera bazy malaurie je vous
dis maintenant mittenaere m'aide à me
tenais à me taire et il ya en outre
changement dans le jury également oui
nico archambault est remplacé par
patrick dupont avait quand même beaucoup
patrick dupont il a sa place franchement
c'est nul mais ma patrie on peut voir le
verre à moitié plein se dire que chalon
revient et moi ça me fait plaisir
surtout l'info et on a donné sais c'est
que c'est camille combal qui va
présenter des mares évidemment ah oui va
lui donner les pleins pouvoirs il n'a
pas simplement lire sur un point leur
char à un petit peu plus at on dit ce
que vous connaissez un peu le format je
n'ai pas la place qu'on peut projeter ce
pas ya pas de place mais est usé est
donc en jeu faisant venir ils veulent un
petit peu et vous finirez tout ça et je
pense que j'adore et imposer sa patte
en revanche un doute sur itunes et iris
me tonnard parce que soit elle est
effectivement dans ce soit des
animatrices est possible